is the first major boxing game uh in
over a decade it's been a while right
you know I think you know we feel like
uh boxing a gaming fans deserves
yes
it's been a long time we're a small
Indie Studio based in the UK in
Sheffield which is a bit of a boxing Hub
in the UK so our our studio was founded
in order
nobody's making this game
nice
games so that's the reason why a small
studio in the UK
you know
um
this morning
[Music]
do we know okay nice
yeah
they got Roy peanut head okay
what engine are we using yeah
we're actually right now
[Music]
and so that's why you've seen some of
these like this yeah
you know we're looking at if I said
we're looking at Phil Lewis kids for the
Legends you know we have you know
today
is
thank you
so yeah hopefully you know hopefully it
feels good Roy Jones I know he said he's
your guy that's my guy he's been really
awesome to work with
um his model in the game he was like you
can't yeah
idle so all these punches you're seeing
that's all Roy right hey yeah so tell us
about the challenge this is such an
ambitious product so many fighters that
you got classic women's division yeah
like what was some of the challenges to
give people to sign on to this project
but it hasn't been a boxing game in so
long since the original confidence yeah
I mean everything's Hardware Indies
I think it comes down to a couple of
things I think you know one you know we
started out with probably a little bit
even less ambition than where we are
today right like we have sort of a
modest scope for the game and what we
found out is that you know while things
are hard and it was hard to try to get
attention
the game early on once that happened
once people in the boxing seen you
realize what they're
you know they they've all rallied around
us and helped us right so Fighters are
helping us get in contact with spiders
we have people that are watching dream
existently in the World
Series
get in touch with Fighters and that's
one of the great things about this is
you know boxing fans they want a box of
people
anybody else so that's really why we're
here right like there's our passion
dedication but it's also about the
support of people
too yes people people are fans of boxing
games like you know we have a Discord
right we have for a couple of years and
there's people in there every day and
you know sign this fight or you know you
know can you do this can you do that and
so it's really the support and obviously
first early hours
but it's also supportive yeah
yeah
and inside of his face
if you didn't get behind something like
this is supposed to look like this you
mentioned like the WBC right how like
how was it as far as the challenge
thoughts get it because that's it is
vicious even to get them involved in a
game like that yeah you know I'm not I'm
not sure how the first conversation
started I think it's one of these things
that once you once you have certain
fighters in the game and you know
certain number of licenses like people
started coming to us I'm not sure
yeah Roy yeah
we got you after that first round Roy
touch you up Roy
okay
I want you both up on your d-pad one
time and when you do that you'll see up
on the d-pad when you move around this
is called loose movement your hands are
a little bit lower
okay Roy get loose come here Roy I want
you loose
down now are there disadvantages
but yeah I mean you're more likely to
you know to hit a flash knock down or
Flash field so you know move on unboxing
is about choice and variety and the
style of the fights right so it's about
do I want to be all right that's out of
your head do I want to be a counter
puncher you know
like we want to be able to give people
those sort of almost bust this side of
your face
early on we're just getting started
early active Payback
[Laughter]
um
a lot of the punches don't have a feel
like an impact okay right so
the nearest competitor will be fight
night right so that's because that's you
know old enough graphically uh HDR wise
uh it looks phenomenal the movement how
is that movement better oh okay okay
it's better than Fight Night movement
impactful punches
I say it's harder because you're doing
it in a 3D space so what you're trying
to do like I don't I didn't feel like
gut punches okay I didn't feel yeah okay
Jabs right hands over the top now we
talk about a lot of very issues he said
with the Jabs of the way yeah so I mean
the directional punching is really
really important right so you can throw
that jab forward you can throw it
backwards you can throw like a pivot job
right what I noticed oh okay so like
going into that what I noticed when I
was doing my movements right so normally
you do a step back jab you look at the
feet so when he stepped back and he
jabbed he shortened the jab off on the
distance but when I was coming in
forward he stepped into it leaned into
the jab in a head boy head back so I
understood that the the positioning of
the punches played a whole big part in
it so it's more stuff in it than fight
night right mine's a little nitpick as
far as yeah
it's a nitpick because there's too many
nuances going on at the same time so
overall they caught everything but I
want him to get a chance to redeem
himself with a character a built-in
excuse me
no that's a sweet tooth yeah
I said no rematch
winner so
Lewis
it's not my fault it's not my fault well
you can control these back out
okay so you have you don't have PVC
Fighters
where they're you know
[Music]
they got a lot but really respect the
ambition of the studio I gotta I got a
two that uh the boxing Community has
been these guys
what you call it um
[Music]
is out there so
questions
this Roy body frame looks different than
heavyweight boys body frame
um do y'all account for Mass when y'all
are doing it because don't be wrong but
I don't think it I don't think it is it
looks like it's different everybody
looks different the ray
excuse me
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
come out
at the same time
on the left trigger like wow you're
hitting the directions
a clear slip you can do the kind of like
full counter to this type of uh fire
like that
you gotta punch yourself out punch
yourself out without a knockout like
this in terms of the decision and the
judging oh what are they looking for
yeah that's uh that's actually a really
good question so you'll notice as you're
playing the game every three rounds
four cars that'll pop up at the bottom
of the screen but it's kind of like the
TV talking yeah this is what we think
it's not the real one not the real one
right so what we've actually got is a
pool of several dozen judges
and they care about certain things a
little bit more than others gotcha
nothing so like
one judge might care more about your
connection percentage
a little bit more
[Music]
and stuff like that so you know there's
there's damage in the game you can cut
somebody you see a cut start hitting
that crust right we stop the fight yeah
they got way more than fighting yeah
it kind of reminds me of MLB to show
like the personality umpires right so if
you're saying we can touch it one of my
favorite powerful
favorite kind of thing
a little bit different
um you know we wanted we want it to feel
right we want to feel better and nothing
is definitely like the thing we're
continuing to balance into
now that we're uh in Early Access like
that's the best part
it's like yeah everything about stamina
to damage to how does this fighter
rating need to be different you know all
that kind of stuff so I think is
definitely a better part of that as well
I think some of the judges right now are
probably better than others
and that's part of the Early Access
experience it's super helpful for us to
be able to get that feedback understand
what people are thinking yeah they'll
start calling judges out by name
okay okay
what's going on oh the sugar sugar
Roy head ain't right
oh ah you can go get that off
together you ain't gonna get that old oh
he good me
[Music]
okay okay
it's okay
boy get your hands up
oh yes
when you're when you're uh trying to
evade yeah push in the left in the left
stick like that you can slip you see
that you just did a rear flip right
there yeah and then you can come back
off that and throw that right here you
can throw it through the crown off the
slip yeah yeah oh but the problem with
Roy is
I think
no oh you got to keep it oh it's tough
you got to keep it in between
so we both found out that Royce up
I
don't accept no worries
you know when Roy get wobbled yeah right
his hand didn't go up in the first round
I was able to do a lot of stuff like
when he saw it was yeah he was moving it
was all good yeah I love the fatigue
yeah I love the fatigue and it's like
you lose a little bit of yourself every
round more damage you take you're going
into that next round a little bit less
of yourself right so boy footwork was a
little bit slower his hand's feet was a
little bit slow and his movement was a
little bit you know slow diminished I
love that fact because a lot of boxing
games don't cover that all right so no
no yo we're trying to we're trying to
make it
you guys working with him see I do my
own boxing on Saturday combat talk with
the king I know benavidez fights uh
Kayla plant this weekend was one of the
people real early on
you know it's funny
we wanted to have an event
going on you couldn't fly everybody out
to the UK so him and a couple of other
guys just came to my house in North
Carolina and was playing the game
they came and I saw everything I've been
following you guys for a minute it's
really good stuff so look Undisputed
Early Access right now yeah right yeah
where could people finally get their
hands on it when they looking for
release and what can they do to support
the game I don't have a date for you
um for for release it's working away
from Early Access we want to get there
as soon as possible we'll be on Console
yes we'll be on Xbox and SMX I mean to
support us like if you're on Steam you
can check us out on Early Access or
wishlist us we'll follow our social
channels
um and yeah let's talk about bigger
questions
um the DLC
um yeah because you know being that butt
is running
um we went to DLC so we can actually
make the fight but I've noticed like uh
benavidez uh Caleb plant and this is a
huge contention of foxes like the cholo
Brothers right so uh we I got a tweet
PVC or something because we got to get
there
Fighters arrows stop playing
we do have plans
all right
we do have a plan okay
yeah yeah people see guys and I noticed
that that kind of takes a huge chunk out
of today's boxes right now as far as
Legacy boxes yeah I mean I think there's
people that you know will sign with us
later on at some point right like we
reach out to everybody
biggest problem with the license right
to license each writer and when they
kind of went away from it was because of
Floyd Floyd acted so much money to be a
licensed fighter yeah uh did you find
that as an obstacle in getting these uh
fighters to be licensed or to the game
or it's a complicated question right
because like with the boxing games
you're licensing everybody individuals
things that people care about are going
to be different right and so you
us I mean we'll never assume somebody
just wants to be in our game like we
want we want people to want to be in the
game right and if there's a way to make
it happen if we can make it work we'll
figure it out but we want to have the
best fighters in the world
uh certainly Fighters are talking to
right right the game continues
for us this is not
drop the game and it's all it's all over
right right okay that was my next
follow-up question my follow-up question
is do you have a cap on where you at are
you like listen you can't keep pursuing
more people to put a cap here for right
now and then we can do DLC later and
bring in more characters and keep the
game refreshing because in in the boxing
World new Fighters emerge every day yeah
right so that will keep the game
question it looks like the graphics
required right a long time uh and you
have the plate mechanics that is forever
but as far as don't ever changing boxing
rosters yeah so I mean it's really about
as fast as we can put fighters in the
game and make them
look right you know it's more of like
the
fighters in there started really active
over in
um so yeah I mean I think we'll look out
for those opportunities right now for
sure it's not a fight we're ready to
just sign you know as many fighters
gotta make them all yeah exactly right
um you know yeah I mean I think the door
is open you know
steps up you know I mean there's you
know they said you're fighting the Box
people out there that always adapt
and it has a big win you know uh
go check that out